les entreprises limoges bonjour ici avec
notre superficie de plancher on est
correct pour pau avoir besoin du
passeport vaccinale cette quincaillerie
de l'assomption reçoit beaucoup d'appels
depuis quelques jours des entrepreneurs
en construction curieux de savoir s'ils
doivent présenter un passeport vaccinale
pour entrer
heureusement pour eux la surface de
vente de ce magasin se situe juste en
dessous du seuil requis par la santé
publique je trouve ça devient extrême
pas mal pour pour l'implant rouichi
dakar que des hôpitaux et tout ça mais
lors qu'un qu'on est rendus là on est
déjà de l'hamza voir nos matériaux non
mais sans surplus ça vient comme un
fardeau de plus que nous de plus qui
s'ajoute qui s'y ajoutent qui donna sa a
pas donné grand chose au niveau mieux
gaïa ou une épopée qu'ailleurs on est
des milieux pendant ces 20
la circonscription de françois legault
et semi rural elle regroupe quelques
petites municipalités du sud de
lanaudière dont celle de l'assomption le
village dont l'économie repose en grande
partie sur son collège régional son
théâtre très prisé et les multiples
commerces qui en dépendent c'est être
autrefois le bastion péquiste de jacques
parizeau c'est maintenant celui de la
cac l'enfer
c'est le papa de toutes les deux mais
quoi ce sont quelques uns parlent en
berne sur le vo
comment cette année dans l'ensemble de
tout ce qui se passe mais
personnellement pour le travail de
monsieur legault moi j'ai rien à
critiquer quand elle faisait monsieur
legault je vais voter pour vous
j'avais mon petit commerce j'ai dû
mettre la clé dans la porte j'ai perdu
beaucoup de clients ter en esthétique
cette résidente de l'assomption déplore
la fermeture des commerces imposée par
le gouvernement legault des gens ici en
village travail dans les petits
commerces alors si tout est fermé mais
l'économie roule pas ce que ça vous fait
reconsidérer peut-être votre perception
du gouvernement ou de monsieur aulas la
wii à voir comment dans d'autres pays
traitent la cover de la pandémie je
pense qu'on aurait
à regarder autour de soi
cela dimitile mon habitude j'ai un
line-up loger des étudiants et des
enseignants j'ai des gens du rotor qui
viennent les bureaux sont toutes en
télétravail c'est tout sauf un un effet
de boule de neige quand on lui demande
si elle appuie toujours son député local
la boulangère hésite j'entends par gara
personne parce que je pense je sais pas
si quelqu'un d'autre est parvenu mais sa
portée à réfléchir à tous les aspects
la circonscription adjacente à celle de
françois legault est également détenu
par la cac la députée locale connaît
bien des lectorats de la région c'est
ainsi je pense que les gens ont de la
misère à comprendre pourquoi alors
qu'ils ont été exemplaires qu'ils
doivent subir certaines restrictions
pour le 10 % qui ne répond pas encore à
la demande donc peut-être une
exaspération qui s'installe vous disais
la semaine passée qu'on voyait la
lumière au bout du tunnel le premier
ministre le goût répète constamment
qu'il voit la lumière au bout du tunnel
on ne prend rien pour acquis on souhaite
naturellement que la population soit
derrière nous et qui comprennent les
raisons pour lesquelles on a pris des
décisions
[Musique]
les électeurs de l'assomption non pas
tout à fait la même vision on n'a pas
les mêmes vieux je pense pour les mêmes
lunettes ça fait longtemps que j'y vois
même sens en éveil et loin en temps dans
l'air encore bien loin
[Musique]